こんにち..痛ッ！やば　普通に痛かった
ネタじゃないからな　ネタじゃないからな？
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
大変お待たせしました
質問コーナーです
実を言うとですね
質問コーナーの編集とか
質問探すのは楽しいんですけども
面白いのが多くて選ぶのがすごい大変なんで
正直やりづらいです
いや、そんなことはないよ
やりづらいとか言っちゃうとダメになっちゃう
楽しいんだけど
その答えたい質問が多すぎるから
それのピックアップにものすごい時間かかっちゃいます
申し訳ないです
というわけで早速いきましょう
また機会があったらすると思うんで
もし選ばれなかった人泣かないで
2回目があるだろ？な？だろ？あるから
またよかったらコメントしてください
ではいこう
どうせ答えてくれないからいいや
スズカちゃんかな？
スズカちゃん
どうせ答えてくれないからいいや
うん
俺はそういうマイナス思考あんまり好きじゃないな
どうせ答えてくれない
そんなことは必ずしもないとは言えないだろ？
だから俺は
何事も諦めないでやることが大事だと思
あなたは誰ですか？
まあせっかくこういう場面なので教えましょう
俺様は
世界が認めた伝説のイケメンヒーロー
グレードはじ
STAP細胞はありますか？
STAP細胞はあります！
天界と魔界の境界線にはどのようなコストが闇を解き放つのですか？
天界と魔界の境界線のコストか
これに関しては私も一回調べたことがあるが
中々簡単なコストではないぞ
なんなの？
”なんなの？”こっちがなんなのだよ
”なんなんですか？”いやこっちがなんなんですか
だから誰なんですか？
いやいやだからなんなんですかこっちがだからなんなんですか
トイレしてください
だからなんなんすか
なんなんす
狂ってください
きたなぁ・・・
俺も２２だからさ
狂うとかそういうのあんまりやりたくな
へぶいうふえくぃｈｒｙうｒひｆｈｆｄｊｂふｇ
お前遠回しに死ねって言ってるだろ嫌だ！
アゴドリルじゃなくてアゴシャベルだわ
まあアゴシャベルは良い人なんですけども
危なっかしい所があるので
まあこれからもドッキリで懲らしめようと思います
足でパズドラしてください
あーー
８コンボ８コンボ８コンボ８コンボ８コンボ
５ターンスキル封印
ぴよおおおおお
好きなアーティストは誰ですか？
遊戯王カード何枚持ってますか？
好きな女優さんは？
動画を作るうえで大切にしてることは何？
１０秒でピカチュウ書いてください
10秒だろ？余裕だよ
よーいスタート
僕のことどれくらい好き？
５億！
はじめしゃちょーの寿命は？
はじめしゃちょーの経験人数は？
５億！
スーパーサイヤ人になってください
*ドアベル*
すいませんね
オイラの質問コーナーはこんな感じです
もう基本適当なので
また質問コーナーがあったらよろしくお願いします
じゃあな